let's talk about that
i'm really glad that something i've been
saying for a couple of months now is
getting more attention it's not getting
more attention from me saying it to be
clear what i mean is i'm glad other
people are coming to the same conclusion
which is that by all accounts
republicans should do very well in the
upcoming midterms now in we're under six
under nine months away from the midterms
one of the best chances at republicans
not doing well is the explosion of the
internal disagreements in civil war that
we're increasingly seeing within the
republican party which we have been
covering
david seiders and natalie allison wrote
about this in a piece for politico
called trump's circular firing squad
threatens republican midterm gains and
this outlines a lot of what we've been
saying
and the article says
nine months before the midterms nearly
everything is falling the republican
party's way from joe biden's dismal
approval ratings to rising gas prices
and a seemingly never-ending pandemic
yet as the rnc concluded its winter
meeting here on friday it was censuring
two of its own
representatives liz cheney and adam
kinzinger and decrying the house's
january 6 select committee for what
ronna mcdaniel the rnc chair called the
quote persecution of ordinary citizens
who engaged in legitimate political
discourse that had nothing to do with
violence at the capitol in a year in
which even many democrats acknowledge
the republicans will likely win the
house and despite republican lawmakers
and strategists pleading with
republicans to keep their focus on
pocket book issues and on biden the rnc
is still recasting the events of january
6th and chasing down enemies of the
defeated former president donald trump
they go on to say
for all the energy he creates at the
party's grassroots his stranglehold on
the party is emerging as one of the
biggest threats to the republicans
otherwise bright prospects in november
he has singled out ten house republicans
for extinction he's attacking republican
governors backing primary challengers
meddling in senate races where it may
lead to the nomination of flawed
candidates ill-suited for a general
election he's fomenting rebellion
against the party senate leader mitch
mcconnell and this week in salt lake
city it was david bossie the former
trump deputy campaign manager leading
the effort to kick cheney and kinzinger
to the curb read the entire article but
it gets to the really key point which is
a sad point
for us right i care about the left
the left is really failing right now
it it's just really failing in terms of
setting itself up
to do well nine months from now in the
midterms
sadly like it it it really pains me to
admit this but the person best
positioned to save the country from
trumpian insanity is trump and
trumpist's sabotaging their own midterms
it's tragically sad that this is the
case for the democratic party right now
but with under nine months to go until
the midterms i'll take any help i can
get and so when we see trump doing this
insane stuff we see republicans
censuring adam kinzinger and liz cheney
last week i told you that george w bush
from another wing of the republican
party has donated the maximum allowed by
law
to both uh lisa murkowski and liz chaney
two people two republicans that
supported the impeachment of donald
trump
i will take all of it
because they're all terrible remember
liz cheney is not our friend liz cheney
when the rubber met the road voted with
trump most of the time so it's all bad
we're maybe i mean listen are we even
better off
with a non-trump republican than a trump
republican if the non-trump republican
is slightly less crazy but more likely
to get their policies passed we're
poorly off no matter what
so i would love to see the democratic
party get it together
um and take advantage of this situation
where for you know historically looking
it should not be a great midterm for
democrats but maybe it could be
this is the biggest gift we could
imagine and so we have to do everything
we can to encourage the civil war to
continue we'll have more on this on our
instagram page which you can find at
david pakman show